hello everyone and welcome back to the
finals of the magnus crossing chester
it's
magnus cross and versus hikaru nakamura
in round one or rather game one
of their fourth match so hikaru is the
leading 2-1
uh match-wise and now magnus needs to
strike back to
uh level the playing field and already
game one is uh
well it's incredibly entertaining so uh
let's dive straight into it so magnus
with the white pieces opens with
c4 so he abandons e4 not not eager to
fight against the berlin uh so the
english is on the board we have
e5 g3 preparing to vince to the light
square bishop and the knight to f6 with
bishop to g to end the d5
they are immediately striking in the
center we have characters captures
knight of three
and knight the c6 now we have castles
and knights to b6 we've seen this plenty
of times before
b3 and now bishop to e6 and here
bishop to beat you sophie and carrying
both bishops
with f6 strengthening the center as it
was attacked twice
the e5 pawn and now knight the c3 we
have queen d7 by hikaru
and now there is one um one or two games
in the database where rook the c1 was
played but here magnus goes queen to c1
and it is already as a move tended we
have a completely new game so let's see
how hikaru deals with this he
immediately goes knife to d4
it's an excellent square for the knight
plus you free up your uh
c pawn so you can push it forward uh you
have to be careful with white if this
knight moves anywhere the knight
captures i need to just
forks the king and the queen so best
just to eliminate this knight either by
playing e3 and force black to capture
or capture it yourself so magnus says
okay knight characters we have quon
captures
and now knight the e4 and hikaru
castle's queen side so castles queen
side now the
uh this pawn is nicely protected and
here magnus
immediately plays a4 showing that he
probably had this or
similar positions in his home laboratory
as the b3 pawn is now free for grabs or
or is it that's basically the question
does he car want to waste
time to calculate if it's okay to
capture this but it is a very
interesting what happens for example if
bishop captures you can go
e3 let's say d3 and now a5 or you can go
a5 right away this is uh
uh this is better so probably magnets
would have gone for this
and now after the knight moves let's say
knight a4 now all hail breaks loose for
example
a6 you go b6 and now knight captures on
f6
incredible stuff uh after g captures you
you could capture here to go after the
two rooks but also there's the bishop
the c6 now just winning back your piece
so that's pretty pretty awesome queen e6
captures and now
let's say bishop moves to d5 gets this
uh incredibly
complicated position where you have to
figure out if it is this uh
any threat for uh for black so probably
f3 needs to be played at some point but
all in all even though the engine says
it's okay for black hikar would probably
waste
way too much time uh you know uh
working out all the intricacies of the
position and trying to come up with
something
so here he car finds a counter move of
his own d3 and now he asks magnus what
do you want to do here
and magnus continues with a5 he says i'm
not worried about the d
captures on e2 and rightfully so because
if d captures an e2
magnus would continue to go for the
knight captures here he
allows captures the rook for with check
now queen captures
and now after you capture something you
cannot capture with the a pawn because
it's checkmate so you have to capture
with the c pawn but now rook captures
and now again a completely crazy
position but uh you know
uh you you could try to prevent
something like crooked by playing this
but then queen a1 is extremely strong
so you probably want to counter the
light square bishop but then again you
run into
knight captures on f6 and nothing is
good here characters captures both rooks
are under attack
you could play something like this uh
and give up the the bishop instead
but not just bishop captures let's say
queen captures and you could
you could capture uh the the
the rook any uh on the eight but uh if
you capture the rook for example
uh then king captures and you don't
really have a lot to worry about black
is just uh black is just up uh
uh upper bishop so instead you would
capture the bishop here
and now let's say rook h the g8 bishop
to h6 is going for f4
controlling this diagonal even though
white would be down the exchange he
would be
very very happy here so this is what
happens if d
captures an e2 and the hikaru says all
right i'm not interested in this i'm
just going to move the knight
and now comes knight to c5 attacking the
queen
uh the queen the bishop also if the
knight moves the
b7 bomb will be heavily heavily attacked
uh soghikar decides to eliminate the
knight right away
bishop characters we have queen captures
now
attacking the a7 pawn and uh he
currently defends it with king to b8 and
now magnus finds the absolute best
bishop to d4 threatening queen captures
followed by may
so b6 is a must here and now magnus
captures here opens up the f the a file
for the rook however
queen to a3 was a bit more precise here
because
you wait with this your black will never
capture or close this so you might as
well prepare this
and only then go for this but okay
magnus goes for eight captures on b6
right away
we have c captures and now queen to a3
and there's no danger here because the
queen is guarding this
a7 pawn so d captures on e2 by hikaru
now
rook after e1 and now rook to ca
preparing rook to c7 to add another
defender here and also bring the other
rook into the game
so rogue captures an eq and now rook the
c7 as planned and now magnus
switches the attention from the a file
goes rook 8 to e1 now with a double
attack on the bishop
and here he currently needs to go bishop
f5 uh well not that
bishop f5 bishop g4 but rather he goes
bishop to h3
and bishop to h3 is a pretty big blunder
but i'm not going to tell you why feel
free to pause the video and
figure out why bishop h3 is a terrible
blunder
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting the
incredible bishop captures on b6
and for those who just want to enjoy the
show it is that movie yes so bishop
captures on b6 this is what magnus
played
and now the problem is if you capture
with the a pawn uh
yes there's c there doesn't seem to be a
way to remove the knife from d5
and make use of this however there is
rook to e7 that's pretty incredible now
if knight
captures of course this is checkmate so
you would have to move
with something like queen b5 let's say
you do that but now comes
root captures and c7 knight captures and
bishop captures on h3
and the material is pretty cool white is
up upon but also in a much better
position the black king is just busted
yeah it would be completely winning for
white so instead
knight captures on b6 by hikaru and now
rook to e7 as the knight no longer
guards this square
but now queen captures on d2 a very
tricky defense by hikaru
now if captures uh with the idea of
captures and captures the black always
has the
characters and in between characters
with check
so here we have bishop captures an h3 by
magnus instead
and now rook to d8 uh keeping an eye on
that
and that whole d file so you can counter
the white rook and now
queen to a6 by magnus queen king the g2
is a very interesting idea
now definitely threatening this uh
because this doesn't come with
check however here you could go queen d5
check and then after the king moves
you repeat so basically best here would
be just to play rook the a1 with
this threat now uh and of course if
captures then you have queen captures
and you have a very nice threat here on
the on the a7 pawn
uh but okay magnus went queen to a6
first
now with ideas of uh well shifting the
bishop over
to this diagonal but now he carries rook
captures on e7 we have rook captures on
e7 and
queen d1 check and now how does magnus
get out of checks if king g2 just queen
d5 checks so magnus blocks with the
bishop
and now rook d7 this is why it's
important for hikaru to keep control of
the d
file rookie to check rogue blocks and
not rook to e3 magnus needs to find
another way how to how to break through
we have h5 he currently wants the bus to
open the position here so he can start
attacking as well h4 by magnus and the
media the g5 we have captures captures
and now
rook against the e7 threatening
checkmate so rogue d7 hikaru needs to
block this and
rook to e5 now attacking the pawns rook
d5 defending
and again rookie check rook to d8
blocking and
queen to b5 now here magnus defends the
rook this way
but now he car just continues pushing h4
uh we have queen to e5 uh with check
and now king the c8 getting the king out
of the way
rook to e6 now with ideas for rook to c6
but hikaru just happily captures he
doesn't mind going for a nice walk
so rook c6 check king to b7 and queen to
c7 check we have king the a8
uh only move uh and after king is the
bishop covered the a6 square that's so
king to a8 and
incredible as it is there's no way to
break through here
so magnus forced the recapture we have
queen captures on g3 and now knight to
d5
and here for some reason magnus goes
after the g5 pawn it seems like uh
well not greedy but maybe a bit too
optimistic
to just open up the g file for for
hikaru's rook
queen to g2 keeping an eye on this
diagonal uh
is the with the way to go however he
captures uh this on g5
and allows hikaru this uh well instant
puzzle rush move
knight to f4 and now uh you're forced to
react to this i mean
you either capture or you don't but if
you don't then a lot of nasty
discoveries are coming like knights to
h3
not discoveries but i mean i2h3 check
can easily fork the king and queen as
the bishop is pinned here
so you do not want this knight here so
here magnus just captures it and now
rook the g8 to check
king to h2 and now queen captures on f1
winning back material
queen to f3 now threatening nasty
discoveries but now king b8 we have
quintet for
check king the a8 and now queen back to
f3
hikaru moves the king again now comes
rook the h6
not allowing any checks along the h file
but now
queen g1 check king so luckily the h1
square is covered by the white queen so
queen back to f1 check
king h4 and queen to g1 uh so what do
you play here
uh we have queen to f4 with check and
now you can't really allow any
any checks by black because queen h1
will be deadly so king a8 and now we
have a series of checks
queen if queenie for check king to b8 we
have queen e5
check king a queen d5 checking v8 uh we
have queen to b5
with check and now king back to a8 and
there is no way to bring the rook into
the game queen c6 check king b8
queen d6 check king back to a8 queen d5
check king b8
and now clean back the e5 check magnus
just repeats backwards queen to a8 queen
to e4 check
king to b8 and queen to f4 check so
we've done a full circle
queen to a8 and now queen to f3 check
king b8
and again queen to f4 check and now
instead of just repeating once again
it was in this position that the players
agreed to a draw
so really really disappointing game for
magnus who had uh who
who had a win multiple times but it's
such a position
i mean players have to prepare
incredible amount of lines for
uh for every match or like uh they will
play you know maybe even seven games
today and you can't
know all of them in details you can just
you know you know some lines
your seconds prepare them for you and
then you have to you know remember as
many as possible and then you just
run into this jungle and of course uh
with a little time on the clock in a
rapid game it's impossible to calculate
everything
so most of the moves are basically you
know some calculation but
uh most of it it's you know
played by feeling the position so yeah a
great a great defensive skills by hikaru
he really found
that knight queen that nice queen to d2
move uh
and survive the attack so we'll see what
what he can do with the white pieces and
how will this match go
uh tough tough break for magnus in in in
game one
so uh that's uh the game i do hope you
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank uh
russell lloyd mark d montgomery scott
melis
richard furman and um uh cassie johnson
for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
finals checking out any wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day